hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the try not to laugh
challenge now as you know this challenge
has been done many many many many many
many many many many many many many many
many many people are desperate to laugh
so these videos or these videos come up
and then people do videos of people
watching videos where they laugh keep in
mind this is all for your safety the
unbridled humor that's contained in
these videos it's just too raw for you
to process by yourself if you were to
watch it without the filter of me to
absorb some of the laughter then my god
here your your brain would just implode
from implode from all the laughter and
then explode because that's how
implosions work I'm starting out with
reddit's try not to laugh challenge
because it's by far the highest rated
video that I've seen there's a ton of
videos that have a lot of views and not
that this doesn't it's got 11 million
but there's other videos out there that
have ton of views but not well like
alright whatever my humor shields are at
maximum bring it on
ah didn't laugh
nope that didn't get me I had [ __ ]
convulsions in my chest but that's not
laughter oh there's gonna be harder than
I thought there's a reason that this one
is highly rated I can tell playing
football blind I'm a giggly [ __ ] by
Nature oh let me come
rémi sit speak good boy I've seen that
video before and I love it a lot when I
first saw that I laughed for like five
minutes straight I love that video you
guys say Colorado Colorado
at the show you can't you can't double
wammy with something I haven't seen and
then go blah a few minutes later the
bear was spotted behind this home in
Moreland Hills this recreation
identifies how witnesses say the bear
escaped into the woods
okay I've lost probably many times now
but I'm gonna keep going because I owe
it to myself
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I I honestly didn't think I was
gonna get got uh that early but man that
was actually legitimately a good one you
know what I do like though there's one
video that there's videos that I found
recently I it's it's music videos
without music alright that did not go
very well for me unfortunately or
expectedly I failed the challenge I'm
sorry I've got too much joy inside my
soul and I laughed very easily but I got
a funny feeling that you guys at home
also failed so let me know if you did
let me know if you didn't and if you
have other funny videos there's tons and
tons of funny videos available on the
internet all across the internet for
everybody to see so if you got more that
you want me to not laugh at let me know
down in the comments below and thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye